is it a mistake to imagine that equality
can be engineered by socialist planning
should we be skeptical of those wrapped
in fine ideals or is there a form of
socialism that can deliver on the dream
that's sort of going to be discussing
today so here on the panel we have Leo
panitch who is emeritus professor of
political science at York University in
Toronto on my left here I have Yaron
Brook who is chairman of the iron Rand
Institute and on my far left literally
anyways cami
who is a Conservative MP for Safran
Walden so Leo over to you
thanks Mary Anne in one of Barbara
Kingsolver
remarkable novels a woman asks her lover
did you ever dream you could fly and he
replies not when I was sorting pecans
all day and she presses on and says but
really did you ever fly in your dreams
and he answers only when I was close to
flying in real life your dreams which
you hope for and all that is not
separate from your life it grows right
out of it
Terry Eagleton the great British
philosopher who wrote in a volume I
added on necessary and unnecessary
utopians back in 2000 that the only
authentic image of the future is the
failure of the present in its inability
to redeem glimpses of our potential
afforded by our own experience and if
you'll allow me finally and I think this
comes straight out of the previous two
quotations Marx once said socialism is
not a state of affairs to which reality
will have to adjust itself but a real
movement which abolish --is the present
state of things so just to make it clear
where I'm coming from socialism is not a
model it's not an economic model it's
not an abstract utopia it's not Thomas
Moore it's not even the much greater
Robert Owen socialism is always the warm
element in human life which is aiming to
unleash human democratic sympathetic
reciprocity in our lives it is certainly
not as is most commonly and mistakenly
claimed state versus market I'll stop
there
that's interesting okay Yaron so the
first thing to comes to mind when when I
saw the title socialist dreams is
nightmares socialist nightmares because
that's the only thing humanity has
experienced when it is adopted socialist
dreams its experienced a nightmare but
it's not just that socialism has failed
everywhere that it is being tried from
the gulags to the timão to Venezuela
right now to the kibbutz in Israel but
that ideologically as an ideal I think
socialism an inherently corrupt ideal it
is based on an inherently corrupt moral
philosophy and therefore has to fail
because it is antagonistic to human
nature and it's agonistic to proper a
proper respect for ethics socialism is
based on the philosophical notion not
that we should be nice to one another
not a reciprocal with the prosody which
is the hallmark of capitalism Rissa
prosody but of the idea that the
individual should be sacrificed to the
group and you can fill in the you can
fill in what the group constitutes you
can fill in you know if it's the polity
Rhian or if it's some other form of
group but it's the idea that the
individual at the end of the day does
not matter though what matters is some
kind of social utility some kind of
well-being some kind of mystical form
platonic form of the good that is not
actually attainable for any individual
but somehow we have as a group and to me
any time you want to sacrifice an
individual you want to literally do
human sacrifice which is what socialism
has always done it's that is evil that
is the essence of what evil means so I
oppose socialism not only because it
obviously has been a dramatic and and
overwhelming failure in practice but
because it has failed because is so
compatible with human morality with the
strive towards individual virtue and
with the focus that we have had in the
West since the Enlightenment on
individual flourishing individual
freedom individual liberty which i think
is what the west and now beautifully
globally is the essence of a civilized
civilization the idea of the sanctity
the sanctity of the individual and
placing an individual first as the end
thank you thank you Kenny
thank you Mary Ann um I think there's
something in that yarn that I can agree
with because I'm someone who does
believe in individual liberty and
personal freedom that's that's what my
philosophy is about and I don't think
that it is compatible with socialism but
I'm coming at it from me from a
different angle because I've actually
been through it where I lived
we had socialism they didn't call it
socialism I grew up in Nigeria and this
I think is one of the greatest tricks
you know with apologies to Chris
Macquarie who wrote the usual suspects
that the greatest trick that socialism
ever achieved was making people think
that it hadn't been tried properly yet
and that's why we keep having the the
conversation about it even though we
have seen time and time again what the
results what the results are we've seen
in fact two countries split themselves
into by their I mean Germany and Korea
where they tried the two different
models and the model that always that
the socialist model always ended up with
people trying to get out and getting
shots for doing so literally wanting to
escape it and I think that that is what
you will always have with socialism but
the question which we were given was can
it ever worked and actually it was very
very controversial I do think in a very
very limited set of circumstances which
I'll elaborate on later you can have it
but I don't think that you will like
what it is that you what it is that you
see and I think that the the tragedy of
some of the discussions were having now
is that there's a new generation that's
never really experienced it certainly in
this country or in the US
and be they have an idealistic sort of
utopian view of what it could be if only
people just got it right which is where
my own personal experience comes from
and I think in particular people say
that Nigeria wasn't socialist that what
the problem with it was was corruption
one of the greatest tragedies of African
when African countries got their
independence was that it was in the 60s
when socialism and that you know
philosophy was in its heyday and almost
universally every African country chose
a socialist model whether it was Julius
and Yuri in Tanzania whether it was
primary in promoting Nigeria you know
goner even in Nigeria in in Senegal
everywhere it was the ideal that they
looked for and it caused so many
problems where if you look in Asia with
other countries that didn't necessarily
go down that path and what happens when
and I know Leo says it isn't about state
versus markets I'd be quite interested
to hear more about that because that's
not the socialism which we were taught
in schools and that's in the textbooks
but that when you do have the government
being the owner of every single thing
and being in charge of everything it
does foster it does foster corruption it
gives them an unlimited power which is
so dangerous and it crushes the
individual okay so what we're going to
discuss to start with is whether we can
achieve equality through some form of
centralized planning which is generally
what socialism is about and I my worry
is that you have almost defined
socialism out of existence in in in in
in in your pitch at the beginning by
saying it's not about Marxism it's not
about state versus market it's purely a
question of affinity but I mean we all
feel affinity with each other we can all
be socialist but we we need to talk
about socialism in action socialism in
public policy socialism far government's
and so if you've defined that out of
existence how can we even talk about it
why hardly define Marx out of existence
and it was Marx who said
that socialism's about as John did John
Stuart Mill the full realization of
individual capacity and the notion that
Marx or any socialist believes that the
existing state the pre capitalist state
or the existing state and the capitalist
society is the institutional structures
through which people would be able to
realize their democratic collective
potentials is absurd no one would claim
this indeed in not only the Marxist
tradition but in the Social Democratic
one in the liberal one for that matter
the state is seen as an imposition on
society not as an expression of it so
let's then go back to this question of
central planning central planning was
introduced in capitalist societies
during World War one
it was the mobilization of all resources
by the state in order to prosecute the
war these were capitalist states
although pre-capitalist ruling classes
landed classes were still powerful
within them and in my view that was an
element in what produced the war
although obviously a capitalist
competition for colonies not least in
Africa which most of which were secured
and turned basically into capitalist
societies as colonies and remained as
such in Nigeria after independence and
shale-oil indicates that's where central
planning was introduced it is true that
Lenin looked with admiration on the
German post office but he did not look
with admiration on German central
planning with its direction of labour
its conscription of trade unions and
labor etc if you want to understand how
that evolved in the Soviet Union
it was not something that was a model
that they imposed you have to understand
it in the context of the civil war the
invasion of the Soviet Union by the
forces that were victorious in world war
one and it was a unfortunate response to
that civil war and I think as Isaac
deutscher pointed out the great
historian of Stalin the journalist for
the economist here in Britain what
happened during the course of the war
was that the anarcho-syndicalist turned
out more popular than the Bolsheviks
when you had competing parties but digit
parties were done away with because it
was never thought by socialists that
once workers had been won to socialism
they might no longer support it and they
responded disastrously disastrously by
closing off freedom of expression
competing parties etc were criticized
immediately for this most famously by
Rosa Luxemburg why this is why she's a
hero of the Democratic Socialist Left
not only do you not have Liberty when
you don't have competing parties freedom
Association what especially matters in a
socialist society is workers develop
ordinary people developing the
capacities to govern and you can't do
that where you have bureaucracy closing
that off so yes the crack existed in
Soviet socialism it was resolved by 1924
you're quoting from Leonard Cohen he's
thinking of this there is a crack in
everything let's ring the bells that
still can ring but he thinks and I think
there was also a crack in social
democracy let me just finish with this
would Eagleton says it is the failure of
the president in terms of in terms of
redeeming our possibilities this is what
redeems the socialist vision and the
attempt by us socialists as democratic
socialists to find a way for that not to
happen
and it is as opposed to what we just
heard the appalling failure the
appalling failure of neoliberal global
capitalism to realize most people's
potential as we see in the way the gloss
is off of it everywhere
the tragedy of course is that the
failure of Soviet socialism much more
importantly the way in which social
democracy the Third Way Blair ISM all
the European Social Democratic parties
embrace neoliberal globalization leaves
them now bereft in terms of speaking to
their own constituency okay okay I'm
gonna cut you short there but I want to
ask so we've had now 101 years since
socialism was first introduced in
government well if you count for 1917
onwards in what country in which country
in that century has there been
successful democratic socialism with as
you say freedom we're not talking about
its betrayed all over the world so
whereas it worked
it isn't a model that's been imposed
it's an outgrowth of particular
societies in particular times in
conflict internally and in conflict
externally you say that's to say
socialism in Cuba didn't work did
capitalism in Cuba work socialism in
Cuba didn't come out of a model it came
out of the failure of capitalism in Cuba
and what happened to socialism Cuba
cannot be understood from beyond the
fact that it sits on the periphery of
the greatest empire in world history
right did socialism in Mozambique work
no but one has to understand that
obviously in terms of the conditions of
Mozambique if social resources its place
in the world you fighting point um I've
been going through a hundred capitalist
societies which we could say fail fail
in Aaron's terms in terms of Liberty
let's look at the number
capitalist dictatorships in history
indeed my fear today with Trump with the
xenophobia that people are being
appealed to is that just as it was said
in the 1930s he who speaks of fascism
without speaking of capitalism should
remain silent I fear today that he who
speaks of capitalism without speaking of
fascism should remain silent it may be
we will turn to socialism because the
alternative in the name of individual
freedom is to treat everyone else as an
asset so you're basically saying it's
the least worst ok how can we know it's
not necessarily it's what we can do to
realize our potential once we free
ourselves of being treated as assets yes
people with property but where is it
actually worked in a democratic way with
freedom I'd like to come back on a
couple of things that that Leo has said
there is there's a general conflation
between capitalism and free markets they
are not the same thing one of them is a
method of ownership the other one is a
method of exchange you can have free
markets without having the capitalism if
you want and for example if you look at
the John Lewis Partnership for instance
Waitrose that's not a capitalist model
all the employees have a share in the
business and they will have a share of
the profits the coop down the road is
another example there are loads of
different types of models that you can
have while still having a free market
system so the issue around capitalism it
yeah what Lehrer I think is calling
capitalism is what I would call
corporatism where it's about
corporations rather than for me
capitalism is the small business you
having a bakery being able to buy and
sell your own goods that's capitalism
too so when you talk about for instance
shell operating in Nigeria it's
something I know I lived there when all
of this was happening when Ken Sarah was
killed shell was basically an extension
of the Nigerian National Petroleum
Corporation they work together the
people have
to do with what was girls room the price
of oil was set by the government which
is here price controls it's it's as a
tenant its socialism that you have to
fix you know it's about price fixing
price controls to make sure that people
doing overcharge and all that happened
was that the oil price globally went up
and the Nigerian government took money
from poor people and subsidized the
price of oil which was mainly used by
the wealthy because they're the ones who
had the cars they're the ones who had
generators and so on it always has these
sort of perverse incentives where there
will still be a top-class of people
whether you have capitalism or not he
brings the socialism in and still
there's a ruling class as we stall with
Stalin Lenin a ruling class that still
manages to be above everyone else so I'm
very suspect I'm very suspicious of it
I'm also very interested in Leo's
definition of socialism which seems to
be able to morph and move it's very
ethereal and here we can't really grasp
it it's something it's more of an
emotion rather than rather than a
definition which then gives it it gives
it that out that it can never ever be it
can never ever be tried because anyone
who tries it gets it wrong whether they
call it if they don't call it socialism
as we had in Africa then it hasn't
really been tried or as we had with
National Socialism in Germany the Nazi
Party had it in the name and people said
well that's not that's not socialism
either yet we see the same results over
and over individuals being squashed and
crushed and the idea is more important
than the people and that's why that's
why I will never that's why I will never
subscribe to it and when you talk about
you know you said the appalling failure
of neoliberalism to realize individual
potential where else in the world is
individual potential realized more so
than in the West to the point where
millions of people from all over the
world are desperately trying to come
here because this is where they feel
that their ambitions and their
individual potential can be most
fulfilled and that is what they say when
they get off the boat when they get off
the plane it's sad the way we talk about
integration as just you know the as
people just coming for economic benefits
it's not just that this is not a
dormitory where people come to work and
make money there's a lot more about what
we have to offer and it is about that
individual liberty and personal freedom
people do not rush to socialist States
any state that has done it there's no
one beating their doors down to go and
live in Cuba or Venezuela or North Korea
or any of those places and for me look
at the evidence look at the evidence
that that's that I think that's all you
need to do to know that this is
something that can't work but Yaron
surely and there doesn't seem to be any
place in your ideology for fairness and
between people because not everybody is
born with the same intelligence or the
same attributes with the same abilities
and you know the great thing about
socialism surely is that at least they
can get a decent education they can get
decent healthcare they can lead a
reasonable life whatever disadvantages
they're born with well if you go to some
public schools particularly in the in
the poorest parts of England and the
poorest parts of the United States I
don't think you would call the education
the kids get their decent well actually
in some of the poorest parts of London
you get some of the best schools places
like granted I may be I should argue
about London but but certainly in the
United States that's not that's not the
case public education good schools a
massive failure
yeah charter schools have improved
things but charter schools is exactly
what the socialist inclination would
argue against that's not free publicly
provided yes and I think we could
improve dramatically over that as well
when we don't make them free don't make
them publicly provided but let me but I
have to comment on this on this
neoliberalism failure not the time in
neoliberal is because I think they're
way too moderate but I mean to look
around the world today and see darkness
is to have shades to be waving shades I
travel all over the world I've spoken in
60 different countries when I go around
the world when I go to Eastern Europe or
I go to Asia or I go to China or you go
to Vietnam or you go to any of these
countries what you're seeing is that the
creation of markets the ability to have
free markets even in limited
circumstances brings out human potential
people are so hungry to be free as
individuals so hungry to be left alone
from the state dictating every single
aspect of their lives and as a
consequence a billion people over a
billion people have come out of extreme
poverty over the last thirty years and
you can ignore that you could pretend it
didn't happen
but globalization has brought more
wealth to the world has helped poverty
the poor more than any other theoretical
abstract system in human history over a
billion people over the last 30 years
have come out of extreme poverty the
middle there's a middle class today in
India and in in in China that did not
exist 30 years ago 30 years ago 30
percent of the planet lived on under $2
a day today the number is under 9
percent now that should be something we
should be celebrating and asking the
question how did this happen this is
indeed a beautiful thing none of it
happened because of foreign aid none of
it happened because of the exploitation
of Marxist ideology they already had
that it's indeed the rejection of that
Marxist ideology it's the rejection of
central planning
it's the rejection of the idea of the
proletarian that is brought this around
it's it's the fact that dunks are paying
in China as evil Anna bastard that he
was was willing to say look it worked in
Hong Kong maybe we should try this in
the area around Hong Kong and see what
happens we'll just leave them alone and
when you leave people along when you
leave people free then they create
things that exceed our imagination
because you are liberating the human
potential and that is true if you if you
go back to hundred fifty years ago 95
percent of humanity lived in $2 a day or
less imagine your own lives on $2 a day
or less we want we people people tell me
you know we have a lot of anxiety in
life today think about living where
you're growing your own food and half
your children are dying before age 10
that is the world before capitalism
before free market capitalism is the
greatest liberate and human history of
the poor of ever the ninety five percent
who used to be in a junk poverty it is
the greatest it is the greatest system
we have ever come across and the
antagonism towards it I find mystifying
because again human life is
ever ever ever being better than it is
right now and it's it could be a lot
better that we'll agree on because I
don't think what capitalists enough we
don't take our capitalism seriously
enough and there's a trick in your
question right because you have equated
fairness with equality but fairness
never used to mean equality fairness
means getting what you deserve and I
would argue that equality is not what
you deserve some people deserve more and
some people deserve less based on the
value they create how do you define
deserve imma suppose you're born with
special educational needs and it's very
difficult for you to hold down a normal
job do you just deserve to be poor
because you know something was a little
bit wrong with your brain when you were
born in a sense so let's flip there on
what makes it because you were born that
way
what gives you a claim against what I
could use what gives you a claim about
my effort and my values that is I might
help you because I care for you and I
care about human beings but what gives
you a claim against me and in the end
the right to use violence against me in
order to find it I never suggested
violent taxis what is redistribution of
wealth is not taxed as violence against
some for I not paying your taxes the
peroration to capitals you just heard
you can read in the whole first half of
Communists the Communist Manifesto by
carnal trace it is absolutely true and
that's why we're talking about not a
model but historical conflict and
Direction movement
of course capitalism has been the most
dynamic the most productive the most
competitive the most successful economic
system in human history
the bourgeoisie has been the most
revolutionary class in human history
much more than the proletariat
absolutely
and if Marx was wrong he was wrong in
thinking that at a very young age it
didn't have very long to live the book
I've written the making global
capitalism is about how remarkable it is
that a hundred and fifty years after the
Communist Manifesto which so brilliantly
predicts what we came to call
globalization in the 1990s was realized
150 years later exactly in the terms we
just heard where every social
relationship on the face of the earth is
commodified where every social
relationship on the face of the earth is
treated as a derivative asset that's the
world we're in and it is dynamic very
true right and it does produce enormous
wealth it also of course produces
enormous inequality even when it
increases the standard of living of
those at the bottom that's very true so
all of these societies that have become
capitalists in this period
above all Nigeria the notion that
Nigeria never claimed to be socialist
the notion that the first thing the
National Socialism did was to imprison
the trade unionist the social democrats
let alone the communists the only reason
they took their word socialism was
because of the appeal it had to a very
strong German working class the whole
emphasis of fascism was anti-socialist
and it's obvious from who didn't go to
jail and who did who didn't go to jail
were the capitalists that's know that's
not who by look I think I think that's
that's a very heavy history to with the
failure of neoliberal globalization was
not what you're described
as its capitalist successes the failures
are the D legitimation that has come
after 2007 but up to today the largest
number of strikes in the world are in
China by far 200,000 a year right by
people whose standards of living have
gone up who support their extended
families in the in the villages right
that's the largest number strikes the
largest number of suicides the largest
number of occupational deaths in the
world right the same is true of India
where there is a massive middle class
absolutely true but the massive increase
in impoverishment in alienation and
destitution is enormous especially in
the massive cities which you're
connected with when you connect with
someone in Chennai and you know you
think you're calling up BT and it's
actually some educated Indian on the
line who is giving you advice about what
to do to get your phone fixed in that
very city which I'd been where 200,000
women have recently organized against
Nokia by the National Indian trade union
federation the impoverishment is
stunning it looks like Manchester
the point is Japan Chester in 1980 I
totally agree that is not to say
therefore that capitalism is over what
it is to say is that the conflict that
capitalism has always produced the
aspirations it's always produced are not
going to go away that 21st century will
be a century again of socialist movement
and aspiration whether we will get it
right will partly have to do with the
degree of dogmatism on the right with
regard to giving space to do it like
because they have the military
they have the City of London and if
there is not space given to a Democratic
Socialist government to try to turn
finance into a public utility to try to
extend the co-ops you were speaking of
to use a National Investment Bank in
regional investment banks to provide an
infrastructure for those co-ops then we
could indeed face a dictatorial
capitalism or if Jeremy Corbyn totally
transforms himself as a human being
which I don't think he would yes we
could face an authoritarian socialism
the future moment hang on a moment
because what I really wanted to discuss
here is which system goes best or
against the grain of human nature
because you're saying that capitalism
makes us feel alienated and dispirited
and suicidal well I know it's not one
thing but equally when socialism has
been trying to practice that also seems
to go against the grain of human nature
because people seem to want to have an
incentive to work and therefore and in
collectivise farms and that sort of
thing
hardly any food got grown when they got
in in Cuba when people were allowed to
grow their own food and farms suddenly
production went up so I'm just wondering
whether there's something about human
nature that perhaps doesn't work with a
with it with a collector you have
unleashed as many dimensions of human
nature the care that a mother shows for
her child the sensitivity we feel to a
human being and suffering is part of our
human nature the competitiveness that he
thinks is the goal of all human life but
the the the the protection of his
property is also human nature what we
need to do is try to develop those
aspects of human nature that realize
individuality in a social way not in a
selfish greedy
let me get engage in a tax haven way and
to hell with the rich this is a
caricature
it's a complete and utter caricature the
idea that all human relationship read
commoditize my relation with my wife and
my children is not being commoditized my
relation what my friends has now become
audit eyes my relationship with my
social circle and maybe for some of you
your religion has not be commoditized
the idea that these relationships have
been commoditized is just propaganda to
make capitalism be what it is not all
capitalism is and we're gonna disagree a
little bit about capitalism and we're
certainly gonna disagree about what
capitalism is capitalism is freedom
capitalism is the freedom of the
individual to live his life as he sees
fit free of coercion fear of coercion of
the state and free of coercion from his
neighbor as a mother in a well free mind
and free of coercion from the coop it's
not what we have today
we don't have capitalism today we have
elements of capitalism but the reason if
so many strikes in China today is
because China is not capitalist but
elements they are elements of capitalism
in China just like their elements of
socialism in China but what makes China
rich what allows the individuals in
China to achieve the human potential and
to live up to the human nature is the
capitalist element it is the socialist
element that is actually suppressing
them and causing them to strike it is in
a state-run enterprises where you're
seeing the strikes it is not in the
private sector that you're seeing the
strikes so it's it's a perversion to
describe capitalism as fascist yes the
capitalist so-called capitalists the
people with money and not everybody with
money as a capitalist the people with
money who wanted to cooperate with the
Nazis didn't go to jail the people with
money who didn't want to cooperate with
the Nazis did go to jail to make this
about class warfare fascism but
particularly Nazis is a complete and
utter distortion of history it certainly
there were rich families in Germany who
put who cooperated with the Nazis and
they should go to hell for that but it
is not true that every single person
with money was a Nazi and that money
defined their cooperation many of them
refused and many of them went to the
concentration camps suddenly if they
were Jewish but even if they were not
fascism is the antithesis of capitalism
fascism is far more similar to socialism
then it is to capitalism a tea that they
edge a socialist socialism communism and
fascism are brothers yes
the Nazis got rid of their political
enemies but they imposed the same kind
of central planning as the Socialists
did in Soviet Union it just had a
slightly different form both the
anti-democratic both the anti freedom
and both want to sacrifice the
individual to some grand view of
humanity whether it's for the sake of
the politician the working classes or
for the sake of the of the race but let
me make one other point about spiritual
values or whatever I mean when I look at
the 19th century when I look at somebody
like Beethoven who was born if you will
under a feudal system and they grew up
into a more capitalist system I see an
artist going from a position where he
was completely a hundred percent
dependent on aristocrats for being able
to create his music and put on
performances by the end of his career
he's doing live events public events
where the new bourgeoisie are paying to
come and see him perform and what you
see throughout Europe is a flourishing
of self-expression a flourishing of the
Arts a flourishing of diverse a massive
diversity artistic spiritual ideological
wonderful debates and discussions and
salons and and and the arts just explode
Jewish people and they're being
democratized in a sense that they are
now accessible to the masses hardly
Kenny in the 19th century for me a
really poignant moment in this
discussion has been just touched on but
Leo saying that the capitalists
cooperated with Nazis and then
completely forgetting what happened to
the Jews whose property was confiscated
and and and what happened to them and it
resonates for me now because when we
talk about a rise in anti-semitism that
we see I think it is actually linked to
link it's linking capitalism and and and
being Jewish there's something about
that link that's coming up and then the
anti-semitism in its own way is an
express an anti-capitalist expression
that's come out in a in a particularly
of
form like that marelit jeremy corbyn
approved of well do you know I'm not
even sure if he really understands
exactly exactly what is going on but I
don't think it's a coincidence that
didn't refer no no I think that I think
that leaves me no no no Leo listen to
what I'm saying let me figure you had
your chance there there are blank spots
which people tend to have when they're
talking about socialism in capitalism
they see the very best in their own
motivations and opinions and the very
worst in their opponents and then they
forget things which the bad things which
have happened by by people on their own
side and it's interesting you know you
talking to me about my during capitalism
it's myth of Nigerian capitalism it
really saddens me because I lived it I
grew up in it I went to a school for
example where we had to take exams and
depending on what you scored your entire
life was decided these are the subjects
you're going to study you possibly known
as the eleven plus here in ribbon
no no no nothing like that at all this
is it's not the eleven plus this is
about if you score above a certain
amount you've got to do sciences and
it's why for instance you find more
African and Asian women in engineering
courses I studied engineering because
it's all state if State designed we I
had an exam which was similar to the
eleven plus and what they did was they
took all the scores of everyone who was
there and they took the exam and they
sprinkled us around the country because
they wanted us to be equal they didn't
want us to go to the school that was
nearest nearest home they wanted
everybody to understand what it was like
in a different part of the country so
can you imagine taking an exam and then
being told that the state is going to
send you to a school 500 miles from home
state boarding school it had to be we
had to do manual labor so that we could
learn but these values and social values
learn about the land and and and and
that and that is the challenge because
people go there and they see markets and
people buying and selling and they call
it capitalism the state defines how much
the currency is worth so you can't buy
for in exchange for instance so a black
market is created where the real value
of the money exists and if someone like
my mother or father wants to come to
this country she buys if she wants you
if she wants it quickly she buys it off
the black market
if she wants it at the official rate she
goes through a bank and she writes for
permission to change her own money her
own money at a rate that is that is
viable that is what the wealthy people
do it always Foster's it always fosters
corruption but people don't understand
this thing they confused the ability of
someone to be able to sell trinkets and
maybe set up a business as as capitalism
went the entire structure when the
entire structure is is is actually about
state control is about state
intervention and telling people what
they should do and how they live their
lives you can't do anything on your own
I think that being my point the
capitalism as a real historical system
has existed far more with dictatorial
governments then it has with with what
we call democratic ones by definition a
tutorial country I think what actually
what is that dictatorship are so common
that you will find capitalism in
dictatorships you'll find social in
socialism in dictatorships but when you
look at the impact on other people's
lives when you look at the bare facts of
do people want to live in these
socialist states no they don't I think
it I think it is just an objective fact
and I'm not taking sides here that there
are more democracies that are capitalist
than democracies that are socialist but
Leo because you're the only socialist on
the platform I'm going to give you five
minutes now to tell us how you finish I
[Laughter]
give you four minutes to explain exactly
how you put socialism in action
retaining Democrats all the Democratic
freedom of expression that sort of thing
in a way that would work in a country
like the UK the democracy that we enjoy
the very limited democracy that we enjoy
in the advanced capitalist societies
and political scientists of every
ideological strike agree with this
cannot be understood apart from the
formation of organizations of the un--
propertied who demanded that they be
included in the state despite being
unprofor m--
of represent elected representation we
had before jacksonian democracy in the
united states first of all a night not
sure any go stream if you wish it was
this job GT was related to it it was the
development of labor movements and the
development of feminist movements after
that supportive usually by these labor
movements arguing that the unprompted
human beings were considered the
properties of the men and their family
should be able to be members of the
state and the democracy we have which is
a real valued and important thing was
won by those struggles it didn't come
out of an abstract model it didn't come
out of the beneficence of the old state
ruling class it was one everywhere and
this is entirely agreed in political
science there was a great deal of
socialist yearning often associated this
with this but not for the most part that
socialist yearning that yearning for
collective protection collective
expression an attempt to democratize our
society to democratize the enterprise to
allow what happens on the hospital ward
to be a matter of discourse and
discussion of a democratic kind to allow
what happens in the mine to be that was
what we were looking for that has not
been achieved that has not been achieved
well we have a three National Health
Service here which is free but what I
was speaking of the Democratic
aspiration what we have is a society in
which the decisions about what is to be
produced where it's to be produced
what's to be invested how it's to be
invested is not determined by States it
is determined by the massive
corporations that control the economies
they do so of course in close
conjunction with the states that protect
their property that codify the rules of
exchange around the world say you go we
have it is important democracy but we
have a yearning which korban expresses
for a much broader a much deeper
democratic economy democratic society
what do you do well if you read the
labor manifesto it begins with
developing the coop system providing an
infrastructure through it for it through
regional investment banks in my view
eventually although this would meet
enormous opposition not only from the
City of London but I fear from parts of
the British state which are the
repressive apparatus of the state to
turn what we all need so badly and are
now so stuck into to turn the city of
London into a public utility this is
what all of our resources pass through
right and without access to that we
can't democratically decide what should
be produced how it should be produced
whether the NHS should be marketized
which is what's happened to it okay
right good so I'd like to thank our
panelists very much and you as well for
coming